"Les marchés financiers s'effondrent
inexorablement."
"Crise financière en deux jours, les bourses
sont passées de l'euphorie à la déprime."
"Crise économique de grande ampleur
aux Etats-Unis, Wall Street,
est toujours en nette baisse ce soir."
"Ce nouveau Krach a gagné l'Asie,
puis l'Europe."
Souvenez-vous, c'était en octobre 2008,
il y a tout juste un an,
un violent séisme provoquait,
l'effondrement des bourses
du monde entier.
Depuis, on nous a tellement parlé de la crise
qu'on a l'impression de la connaître par cœur.
Mais dans le feu de l'action, en a-t-on
bien expliqué les véritables causes ? Pas sûr.
Pour savoir ce qui nous arrive,
le meilleur moyen est encore,
de revenir en arrière, jusqu'aux
origines d'un système devenu fou.
Comment la finance et la bourse ont-elles
réussi, depuis maintenant 30 ans,
à prendre le contrôle
total de l'économie ?
Pourquoi subissons-nous
des krachs à répétition,
qui nous plongent
à chaque fois dans l'inconnu ?
Voici donc, en dix dates clés,
le compte à rebours d'un immense ratage.
10 repères historiques pour nous aider à
comprendre comment une fusée ultra-sophistiquée,
qui devait nous emmener vers
les sommets de la croissance,
s'est lamentablement écrasée au sol.
Vous le remarquerez, le scénario des crises
boursières est toujours le même.
Une bulle spéculative se forme,
puis enfle sans limite,
jusqu'au jour où une étincelle déclenche
une explosion dévastatrice.
À l'automne 2008, ce sera la faillite
d'une grande dame de la banque,
d'affaires américaine Lehman Brothers.
C'est à partir du moment où Lehman
fait faillite le 15 septembre,
il ne faut que quelques jours pour
que l'ensemble du système bancaire mondial,
se retrouve totalement en apesanteur,
et qu'on ait un blocage complet
du crédit dans le monde entier.
Lehman, ça reste une des plus grandes
erreurs de politique économique,
depuis la montée des taux
par la Fed en 1930.
Si une banque comme Lehman Brothers
peut faire faillite, donc valoir zéro,
que vaut une banque comme BNP,
comme Société Générale,
comme Citigroup, comme Bank of America ?
Catastrophe, parce que toutes
les autres banques se disent :
"Je peux mourir demain".
Au lieu de fermer une banque, on a mis
la suspicion sur toutes les banques.
Quand on voit ça dans un premier
temps, on se dit :
Si le gouvernement américain prend
ce risque, peut-être que c'est calculé.
Ils ont sécurisé le périmètre.
Et on arrive lundi matin au bureau et
on se rend compte que rien n'a été préparé.
Que font les investisseurs
dans le monde ?
Ils s'envoient des mails
avec un titre très simple :
"Who's next" : C'est qui le prochain ?
C'est simple, faites la liste
de tous les clients de Lehman Brothers.
Manque de pot, il y a tout le monde.
En France, la Banque Postale qui n'est
pas un modèle de banque de spéculatives,
Même elle, travaille avec Lehman Brothers,
tout le monde est mis en cause.
Et là tout devient possible
et donc on perd tout nos repères,
et c'est la fuite en avant,
c'est la dégringolade complète.
La faillite de Lehman Brothers
n'aurait donc été qu'une péripétie,
si elle n'avait provoqué
un krach boursier sans précédent.
Imaginez 30 000 milliards
de dollars partis en fumée.
La crise financière se prolonge
en crise économique,
la plus grave depuis la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale.
Et là, nous sommes tous concernés,
pas seulement les boursicoteurs.
Nous les travailleurs, nous sommes
la majorité et on ne se laissera pas,
diriger par les riches de la minorité.
On ne va pas se laisser
égorger comme des moutons !
On va se bagarrer !
On va montrer les dents !
Dans le chaos ambiant, un vieil acteur
qu'on croyait définitivement,
retiré de la scène économique
a fait son retour, l'Etat,
Quand le monde de la finance s'est écroulé,
lui seul et personne d'autre,
pouvait encore jouer
le rôle du Sauveur suprême.
Tous les gouvernements ont bazardé
l'intouchable principe du laisser-faire.
Les plus libéraux d'entre eux
en ont avalé leur chapeau,
mais ils n'avaient plus le choix.
Sans la bouée de secours de la puissance
publique, l'économie de marché,
aurait sombré corps et biens.
Notre système de libre entreprise
repose sur le principe,
que le gouvernement ne doit intervenir
sur les marchés qu'en cas de nécessité.
Compte tenu de la fragilité
des marchés aujourd'hui,
et de leur importance vitale pour
la vie quotidienne des Américains,
l'intervention du gouvernement n'est pas
seulement souhaitée, elle est essentielle.
Nous déclarons, chef d'Etat
et chef de gouvernement,
que chacun d'entre nous prendra
toutes les mesures nécessaires,
pour assurer la stabilité
du système financier.
Que ce soit par l'injection de liquidités,
en provenance des banques centrales,
par des mesures ciblées
sur certaines banques,
ou par des dispositifs renforcés
de protection des dépôts.
Par un incroyable mouvement de balancier,
nous voilà donc revenus plusieurs
décennies en arrière, à une époque où,
dans des circonstances identiques,
l'État était venu à la rescousse
des banques et de la finance.
C'était après la crise de 1929,
dont on célèbre en ce moment
le quatre 80ᵉ anniversaire,
triste hasard du calendrier.
Aujourd'hui encore, elle reste
le plus grand traumatisme,
de l'histoire économique contemporaine,
la mère de tous les krachs.
En 1929, l'étincelle qui fait exploser la bombe
financière ne s'appelle pas Lehman Brothers,
mais Photomaton, ou plutôt Clarence Hatry,
du nom de l'exploitant du brevet photomaton
et expert en arnaques financières,
de haute voltige.
Pour avoir spéculé au-delà
du raisonnable sur ses propres actions,
à la Bourse de Londres,
sa holding familiale est acculée,
à la faillite en septembre.
Clarence Hatry est emprisonné, mais la
méfiance s'empare des investisseurs.
Un mois plus tard, la bulle spéculative
éclate et Wall Street s'effondre.
Un jeudi noir de triste mémoire.
Faillites en septembre, Krach en octobre.
Le parallélisme entre 1929 et 2008
est troublant.
Comme si nous n'avions
rien appris du passé.
Si on essaie de comparer la crise
de 29 et la crise d'aujourd'hui,
on voit qu'il y a une source
au départ, la finance,
une inflation exagérée
de la valeur de la bourse,
et de la valeur des marchés financiers.
Ce qu'il se passe en 1929,
c'est d'abord une crise de crédit,
d'hypertrophie de crédit.
Les banques n'ont plus la mesure
de ce qu'elles prêtent.
Elles ne savent plus à quoi
correspond les crédits qu'elles font.
Mais, comme les autres banques,
stimulent le crédit
et la demande d'actions,
elles aussi prêtent, sachant
que si elles ne prêtent pas,
ce seront les autres
qui prendront les clients.
Il y a une surenchère à la
clientèle qui fait que tout le monde,
se lance dans l'offre de crédit.
C'est un processus assez simple
de formation d'une bulle.
Comme cette bulle n'a aucun fondement,
elle finit par éclater.
Et la chute est aussi brutale
que l'engouement.
À partir de là, c'est la panique !
Ils font tout et n'importe quoi.
Ils vendent leurs actions, ils achètent de l'or.
Ce qu'on appelle en anglais les "Animals spirits",
ce sont les instincts animaux.
C'est comme ça que marchent les marchés.
C'est du mimétisme, à la hausse comme à la baisse.
La bourse va perdre en moins
d'un mois 50% de la valeur,
et en cumulé entre 1929 et 1933,
va perdre 85% de sa valeur.
Et c'est la panique,
les petits épargnants qui avaient acheté
des actifs en bourse cessent de consommer.
Les entreprises voient que
ça ne va plus, elles cessent d'investir,
On a un mécanisme multiplicateur
qui se met en place.
Ce qui explique la gravité de la crise,
c'est le fait qu'entre 1929 et 1933,
la moitié des banques américaines
vont faire faillite,
sans que les autorités de l'époque
ne cherchent à l'empêcher.
En 29, au lendemain du krach boursier,
la Réserve fédérale américaine
ne baisse pas les taux d'intérêt.
Elle laisse la situation s'installer.
En plus, nous avons une déflation,
une baisse des prix,
qui aggrave le coût de la dette,
les ménages sont acculés
à vendre leurs biens,
donc ça fait augmenter
l'offre de biens vendus.
Quand l'offre augmente alors que la demande
reste faible, ça fait baisser les prix.
Donc la déflation s'accélère
et devient extrêmement dangereuse.
C'est la grande différence avec la crise
contemporaine, c'est qu'on laisse faire.
C'est la vieille doctrine du libéralisme.
Il faut que le système
se purge de lui-même,
en laissant le système se purger
de lui-même, on provoque une catastrophe.
D'abord une grande récession aux
Etats-Unis et ensuite ce choc,
a été exporté au reste du monde,
à travers le rapatriement des avoirs
américains dans le monde.
Et c'est comme ça qu'à partir d'un krach
boursier qui était à l'origine localisé,
on a créé ce qu'on appelle
encore aujourd'hui,
la grande déflation des années 30, avec
des conséquences économiques très lourdes,
et également des conséquences politiques
puisqu'elle a participé ensuite,
par la misère qu'elle a provoqué,
les tensions économiques et politiques,
entre nations à la course à la guerre
qui a conduit à la 2nde Guerre mondiale.
Et ce sera le déclencheur sans aucun doute
possible de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Et l'Allemagne va être le premier pays
européen à être directement impacté,
touché par la crise américaine.
L'Allemagne va suivre un sentier
presque parallèle au sentier américain.
Le chômage va monter dans les mêmes
proportions en Allemagne et aux Etats-Unis.
Il va monter jusqu'à 25%
de la population active,
alors qu'en France ou en Angleterre,
ce sera 2 fois moins,
ce sera plus atténué comme impact.
Et puis l'Allemagne va tout
simplement connaître,
l'effondrement moral qui va être lié,
à cette crise économique.
Et ce qui est tragique dans l'histoire
allemande, c'est que la crise,
va s'interrompre vers 1933 aux Etats-Unis,
comme dans la plupart des pays,
notamment en Allemagne même.
Hitler, au fond, est élu dans les derniers
mois de la crise, à quelques mois près,
Beaucoup d'historiens pense qu'Hitler
n'aurait jamais pu prendre le pouvoir,
ça s'est joué quelques mois.
Et indiscutablement, Hitler vient au pouvoir
parce que l'économie allemande est en ruine,
et que les gens cherchent
une alternative au système en place.
"Plus jamais ça",
proclament les gouvernements.
Ils ont retenu la leçon
de la Grande Dépression,
quand la Bourse perd la tête
et entraîne l'économie dans sa chute.
L'état ne doit plus hésiter à intervenir
massivement et sans tarder.
Pour retrouver la croissance et le plein emploi,
il faut contrôler les marchés,
garantir une protection sociale, lancer
des grands travaux, organiser la production,
bref, il faut se débarrasser
du libéralisme pur et dur.
Le point intellectuel le plus
marquant de cette époque,
c'est la publication du livre
de John Maynard Keynes,
la théorie générale de l'emploi,
de la monnaie et de l'intérêt,
qui est publié en 1936 et qui va expliquer
tout simplement la chose suivante,
le capitalisme n'est pas contradictoire avec
la prospérité et le bien-être pour tous,
il n'est pas contradictoire avec le plein emploi,
comme le pensait Marx au XIXᵉ siècle.
Keynes dit Non, pas du tout, le capitalisme
est compatible avec le plein emploi,
mais il ne l'atteint pas seul,
il ne l'atteint pas spontanément.
Il a besoin d'être guidé par l'Etat,
par la politique macroéconomique,
et la crise de 1930-33,
démontre à soi toute seule
cette instabilité inhérente du capitalisme.
Indiscutablement, dans les années 30
naît l'idée,
que le capitalisme
a besoin d'être régulé.
Dès 1933, aux Etats-Unis, Franklin Roosevelt,
le président démocrate, nouvellement élu,
avait inventé le New Deal, régulation des
marchés financiers, soutien à l'agriculture,
assistance aux plus démunis,
protection des droits syndicaux,
mais surtout pour remettre
les Américains au travail,
ils avaient multiplié
les investissements publics,
avec la construction de routes, d'aéroports,
de ponts, de barrages hydrauliques.
Le visage de l'Amérique s'est transformé
à marche forcée.
C'est là que nait le keynésianisme
de l'économiste Keynes qui dit :
Quand l'économie est malade,
quand il y a une déflation,
il faut faire ce qu'on appelle un électrochoc,
une relance budgétaire,
qui va doper la demande temporairement,
grâce à la relance budgétaire,
donc aux deniers publics.
À ce moment-là, ça va générer un processus
d'accélération de l'investissement,
un investissement public,
va générer une multiplicité
d'investissements privés.
Et donc à ce moment-là, la croissance
revient, ce qui génère une augmentation
des recettes fiscales et donc l'Etat
retrouve un équilibre budgétaire.
C'est ça qu'on a oublié, notamment
en Europe et en France,
c'est que la théorie keynésienne
de relance, c'est une impulsion.
La santé de Paris
Tout homme bien portant est un malade
qui s'ignore, dit un vieil adage.
Ailleurs qu'en Amérique, c'est après
la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
que l'intervention de l'État dans
l'économie connaîtra son âge d'or.
En France, la Sécurité sociale
devient le symbole,
d'un capitalisme
plus stable et plus solidaire.
La sécurité sociale,
offre le moyen de contrôler
son état de santé et celui des siens,
gratuitement et dans les conditions
les plus simples.
Son nom, son adresse.
Et le voici convoqué avec sa famille,
au centre d'examen le plus proche.
L'État-providence, ce sont
donc toutes ces politiques,
l'assurance retraite, à l'époque,
il y avait des assurances retraite,
mais qui étaient privées, des systèmes
de retraite qui ont été généralisés.
les systèmes d'assurance maladie,
les systèmes d'assurance chômage,
et dans certains pays comme la France
en plus, les allocations familiales.
Ça a permis de garantir les ménages
contre toute une série de risques,
qui étaient jusqu'à présent pris
en charge par l'épargne individuelle,
et donc de libérer une partie
du revenu pour la consommation.
C'est la grande période
de la reconstruction.
C'est une période qui n'est pas
très longue, qui dure à peu près 30 ans,
jusqu'à 70-74.
C'était une période sociale démocrate,
de grande égalité sociale,
et de grande interventionnisme publique,
c'est la période où,
les découverts de la Banque de France
permettent de faire marcher la planche à billets.
Tout ça finance
des investissements publics.
Et là, on a vraiment
une croissance très rapide,
un taux de chômage qui baisse rapidement,
et une société assez égalitaire
qui se développe.
Et puis ce système là se grippe.
La crise pétrolière, c'est elle
qui va brutalement révéler la fragilité,
d'un modèle économique
qui commence à s'essouffler.
En 1973, puis en 1979,
les pays du Golfe, membres de l'OPEP,
décident d'augmenter les prix du pétrole
pour accroître leurs revenus.
Pire, ils menacent d'interrompre purement
et simplement leur approvisionnement.
Les compagnies pétrolières, déjà, sont
accusées de profiter de la situation,
et d'entretenir la spéculation.
Je voudrais souligner ce point. Les grandes
compagnies pétrolières ne sont pas autorisées,
à faire des bénéfices excessifs
et devront fournir au peuple américain,
les chiffres exacts de leurs stocks.
La psychose de la pénurie se répand
parmi les pays consommateurs.
Chacun tente par tous les moyens de se
fournir en pétrole, alimentant,
encore un peu plus la hausse des prix.
Les États-Unis, plus gros dévoreurs
d'énergie de la planète,
prennent soudainement conscience
de leur dépendance.
En France,
on s'en remet au génie national,
pour trouver des solutions astucieuses
au choc pétrolier.
En France, on a toutes sortes de choses.
On a la meilleure cuisine du monde.
Une industrie puissante,
la pétanque.
Une histoire glorieuse.
On a aussi une situation
géographique privilégiée.
La Tour Eiffel et la pêche à la ligne.
Oui, en France, on a tout ça
et bien plus encore.
Pourtant, une chose nous manque,
une chose essentielle,
le pétrole.
Le pétrole, nous sommes
obligés de l'acheter à d'autres.
Cher, trop cher.
C'est notre richesse qui s'en va
et notre façon de vivre qui est menacée.
Alors, que peut-on faire ?
D'abord, mieux utiliser l'énergie.
Et ça, nous pouvons le faire
sans changer notre façon de vivre.
En France, on n'a pas de pétrole.
Mais on a des idées.
Dans les années 70, lorsqu'arrive le premier
choc pétrolier, puis le deuxième,
c'est l'échec, c'est la faillite du modèle
keynésien de relance parce que c'est une phase,
où il y a beaucoup d'inflation qui est
importée à cause de la flambée des prix,
du pétrole et des matières premières.
Comme à l'époque, on a une indexation,
des salaires aux prix. Dès que les prix
augmentent, les salaires aussi...
et ainsi de suite !
C'est ce qu'on appelle une bulle
inflationniste ou un cercle pernicieux,
qu'on appelle également la stagflation.
On a à la fois une récession économique
et une inflation élevée.
Il faut que nous comprenions,
Que la raison essentielle
de la situation que nous connaissons,
tient en une seule formule.
La France vit au dessus de ses moyens.
L'énergie à bas prix, c'est fini,
il faut réduire ses dépenses,
la machine économique
se retrouve au régime sec.
Du coup, tout va petit à petit
se détraquer.
Inflation et ralentissement de la croissance.
C'est un cercle vicieux qui se met en place.
On n'arrive plus à en sortir.
La consommation ne se développe
plus aussi vite.
Les gains de productivité dans l'économie,
dans les usines sont plus lents.
Il y a quelque chose qui se passe
et c'est sur ce grippage,
que renforce évidemment
une inflation très forte,
due en partie au pétrole que naît,
je dirais,
une révolution conservatrice.
Après 30 ans de bons et loyaux services,
l'État-providence,
n'a pas résisté aux 2 chocs pétroliers.
On l'accuse de tous les maux,
d'être responsable de toutes
nos difficultés économiques.
Pour les néolibéraux, le moment est enfin
venu de prendre une revanche sur l'histoire.
Un demi siècle après la crise de 1929,
le traumatisme de la Grande Dépression
n'est plus qu'un lointain souvenir.
Désormais, on peut de nouveau célébrer les
vertus du marché et de la libre concurrence.
À partir de là, il y a un tremblement
de terre intellectuel qui se produit.
et au lieu de comprendre que c'est
tantôt l'offre, tantôt la demande,
on a brûlé le keynésianisme et on est passé
à une nouvelle idéologie néolibérale,
celle qui justement allait tout jouer
sur l'offre en oubliant pour le coup,
les leçons du keynésianisme sur l'instabilité
intrinsèque du capitalisme.
On sent que là apparaît,
une nouvelle idéologie qui se schématise
dans la phrase de Reagan :
"L'Etat, ce n'est pas la solution,
c'est le problème."
Ronald Reagan a trouvé
la solution au problème.
Son élection, juste après celle
de Margaret Thatcher,
ne marque pas seulement l'arrivée
d'un nouveau président,
mais bien l'avènement d'un changement
radical de politique économique.
Son objectif est proclamé haut et fort,
démanteler au plus vite l'État-providence,
et lui substituer
la main invisible du marché.
La grande déréglementation
et les nouvelles formes de production,
qui vont être choisies, plus flexibles,
avec beaucoup plus d'externalisation,
de flexibilité dans la façon même
dont le capitalisme va se penser soi-même,
va commencer par
une formidable désyndicalisation,
et c'est un des facteurs les plus importants
qui vont contribuer à faire monter les inégalités,
de revenus aux États-Unis et puis aussi
casser véritablement l'inflation salariale,
des années 70 où les ouvriers,
à travers leurs syndicats,
cherchent à résister à la dégradation
de leur pouvoir d'achat, elle même liée,
à la hausse du prix du baril,
indirectement, en tout cas.
Tout ce mouvement social est brisé
au cours des années 80,
et ça va avoir une influence très
importante dans les années 90 et 2000,
puisqu'à partir de ce moment là,
on va vivre dans un monde sans inflation.
Milton Friedman, prix Nobel d'économie,
devient l'inspirateur de Ronald Reagan,
et le grand gourou du néolibéralisme.
Pour lui, Keynes et le modèle
interventionniste de l'après guerre,
doivent rejoindre
les poubelles de l'histoire.
Le dollar est fort
et continue de grimper,
parce que les Etats-Unis sont
le pays le plus intéressant,
dans le monde pour investir notre agent.
Ses caractéristiques
sont d'être productif,
d'avoir un taux élevé de rentabilité.
Autre caractéristique : vous pouvez
faire ce que vous voulez,
de votre propre argent,
il n'y a pas de contôle des changes
Le gouvernement n'intervient
pas dans ce que vous faites
Vous avez la sécurité de la propriété
privée et une stabilité politique
La stabilité politique aux États-Unis
peut être,
mais pour le monde du travail,
le début d'une grande instabilité.
Les syndicats de salariés ont beau se
mobiliser, ils sortiront largement perdants
de la confrontation.
Dans les entreprises, le pouvoir
change de main et pour longtemps.
Les deux grands pays égalitaires
à ce moment là sont,
la Grande-Bretagne et les États-Unis.
Ce sont les pays les plus égalitaires
du monde qui, brutalement,
vont devenir les pays
les plus inégalitaires du monde.
Car dans le même temps, en Grande-Bretagne
et avec une extrême dureté,
Margaret Thatcher décide
d'en finir avec l'intrusion,
de la puissance publique dans l'économie.
Elle impose une purge au pays,
le débarrasse de ses canards boiteux,
quel que soit le prix à payer
sur le plan social.
Ce n'est pas uniquement au pouvoir des
syndicats que nous devons nous attaquer.
Il s'agit du pouvoir des syndicats
lié au nombre surélevé de monopole.
Je pense que c'est une mauvaise chose.
Le socialisme a causé beaucoup
de tort à la Grande Bretagne,
avec toutes ces nationalisations.
Si l'acier n'avait pas été nationalisé nous
n'aurions pas tous ces problèmes aujourd'hui.
Nous tentons de nous occuper de certaines
de ces industries nationalisées.
Ce problème est donc bien plus profond
que celui du simple pouvoir syndical.
Le mot restructuration existe
aussi en anglais,
et les mineurs britanniques en font
la douloureuse expérience.
20 000 emplois supprimés cette année.
Alors depuis lundi, c'est la grève.
Ce mineur blessé participait au piquet
de grève volant venu du Yorkshire,
pour convaincre les mineurs du comté
voisin de se joindre au mouvement.
Mais grévistes et non-grévistes
se sont violemment heurtés,
se jetant des briques et des morceaux de bois
avant l'intervention des forces de l'ordre.
Ces affrontements sont intervenus
quelques heures,
après la décision
de la Haute Cour de Londres,
d'interdire les piquets de grève volants.
C'est le 4e jour de la grève
des mineurs qui proteste contre la décision,
des charbonnages britanniques
de fermer une vingtaine de puits,
et de supprimer 20 000 emplois
d'ici 1985.
Alors que le chômage monte en flèche,
Margaret Thatcher n'hésite pas
à s'attaquer aux mineurs,
puissant bastion du syndicalisme anglais.
Après une année de grèves et d'affrontements,
ils doivent eux aussi capituler.
Une défaite hautement symbolique.
Et on passe au capitalisme
anglo-saxon moderne,
les entreprises sont gérées
pour les actionnaires.
Mais ça a provoqué cette exigence
extraordinairement élevée,
de rentabilité du capital
qui est destructrice.
Si on veut que le capital rapporte
20% par an, on fait plein de bêtises.
On ne va pas faire des investissements
qui mettraient du temps à être rentables,
on va privilégier les investissements
à courte rentabilité, on va déformer,
le partage de revenus au détriment des salariés,
on va avoir des salaires très faibles,
ou qui n'augmentent pas
mais c'est vraiment une rupture,
Ce moment où on passe à cette gestion
au profit des actionnaires.
Une grève surprise ! Bravo !
30 tonnes de viande sur le carreau alors
qu'on meurt de faim à Chandernagor. Hourra !
Monsieur Grafouillère, vous êtes un meneur
et vos petits camarades des inconscients !
Vous semblez oublier en effet, mes amis,
que vous n'êtes que des salariés,
c'est à dire les êtres les plus
vulnérables du monde capitaliste,
des chômeurs en puissance.
Le chômage.
Le chômage et son cortège de misères.
- Y avez vous pensé ?
- Non Monsieur.
Fini la petite voiture !
Fini les vacances au Crotoy !
Fini le tiercé !
C'est pourquoi, si vous avez des
revendications de salaire,
vous m'adressez une note, je
la fout au panier et on en parle plus.
Nous sommes bien d'accord ?
Alors, au boulot et plus vite !
Margaret Thatcher et Ronald Reagan
qui s'entendent très bien,
peuvent enfin se congratuler.
Sous leurs airs affables, ils ont
réussi à mener d'une main de fer,
la révolution néolibérale
dont ils rêvaient.
Cette rupture, elle se passe
avec, premièrement,
des politiques monétaires extrêmement
rigoureuses qui vont casser l'inflation.
Deuxièmement, des politiques
de diminution des impôts,
et des dépenses publiques, donc du degré
d'intervention de l'Etat dans l'économie.
Et troisièmement, des programmes
de privatisation,
qui sont liés à des programmes
qui accélèrent,
la montée en puissance des marchés.
Ce sera par exemple pour la place de Londres,
ce qu'on a appelé à l'époque le big bang.
Le Big bang, c'est le terme
choc utilisé en 1986,
pour désigner l'acte de naissance
de la bourse moderne.
Une fois les restructurations
menées sans ménagement,
Margaret Thatcher peut passer
à l'étape suivante.
Redonner aux marchés de capitaux
la prééminence qu'ils avaient perdue,
après la crise de 1929.
Le 27 octobre 1986, elle décide de frapper
un grand coup en une seule journée.
La Bourse de Londres bascule
dans l'ère du capitalisme financier.
Ça se résume à deux choses : concurrence
libre sur les commissions de courtage.
Et surtout accès libre à la bourse
pour les transactions,
avec en général simultanément
mise en place de systèmes électroniques,
qui rendaient les transactions
plus rapides, plus économiques,
et tout le système plus simple.
Aujourd'hui, dans le monde entier,
acheter ou vendre une action,
coûte entre dix et 20 fois moins
cher en monnaie constante
qu'à l'époque.
La concurrence est traduit par le fait
qu'il y a des progrès de productivité,
dans la gestion de ces transactions,
ce qui a permis au grand public,
d'accéder aux marchés d'actions partout.
À un moment donné, on va vouloir créer
absolument de la valeur boursière.
Et les entrepreneurs dans les années 80
commencent à dire :
Je ne suis pas là pour créer des emplois
mais pour créer de la valeur.
On ne peut pas apporter
de capitaux aux entreprises,
s'il n'y a pas un marché boursier actif.
C'est quand même la source principale
de fonds propres, de capitaux.
Pour que l'économie se développe,
il fallait qu'il y ait une libération
du système de financement de l'économie.
Quand je sors d'HEC en 1982,
c'est le début de l'explosion
des marchés financiers,
avec une première phase qui est
une phase qui correspond à ce profil,
école de commerce diplômée,
qui est une phase assez saine.
c'est une phase où les marchés financiers
sont au service de l'économie.
La partie marchés financiers, on était
un sous service de la banque.
À l'époque on pouvait gagner un peu
d'argent sur les marchés financiers.
Les banques étaient prêtes à vous donner
une part assez significative,
de ce que vous rapportiez à la banque,
parce qu'on ne s'imaginait pas qu'on pouvait
gagner des centaines de millions de dollars.
Petit à petit, le montant
sur lequel on jouait,
et les montants sur lesquels
on pouvait gagner ont explosé,
et les pourcentages de ce qu'on pouvait
gagner n'ont pas changé.
On est passé de rémunération...
Au tout début, quand on avait un bonus,
à l'époque, de 50 000 francs,
ce qui fait un peu moins de 10 000€,
on considérait qu'on avait déjà
fait une très belle performance.
Dix ans après, on en était à 3,
4, 5 millionsd'euros.
C'est à ce moment là que naît
le mythe du "golden boy".
Les cheveux gominés, la chemise blanche
et tout ce qui va autour,
les belles voitures, l'argent,
toute cette image.
Je m'appelle Patrick Batemen,
j'ai 27 ans.
Je suis un adepte,
du régime équilibré et de l'exercice.
Nouvelle carte.
Comment vous trouvez ?
Très chouette.
Patrick, t'es si chou !
Oui, Patrick ?
Voulez-vous dîner avec moi ?
Je voudrais une fille,
la vingtaine, blonde.
Mets-toi à genoux.
J'ai tout de l'être humain,
mais pas la moindre émotion.
L'inventivité des petits génies de la City
qui rivalisent avec ceux de Wall Street,
ne connaîtra plus de limites.
Ils conçoivent des produits financiers
d'une complexité inouïe
mais qui rapportent énormément d'argent.
Un vocabulaire jusque là inconnu fait
son apparition, obligations pourries,
stock options, parachutes dorés
et Golden Hello.
Ça devient une espèce de folie,
d'insatiabilité vers la rémunération
qui n'a plus rien de réel.
Il y a toute une idéologie qui favorise
l'homme de la City, le banquier.
Celui qui a fait fortune rapidement.
Au milieu des années 80,
on a des générations entières,
qui sortent d'universités et pour qui
finance = marchés financiers.
Et le rêve, c'est d'être tradeur.
Le rêve, c'est de pouvoir
gagner des millions d'euros.
L'audace réformatrice des anglo-saxons fait
surtout rêver les autres gouvernements,
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche.
En France,
le socialiste Pierre Bérégovoy,
libéralise à son tour les marchés
de capitaux et modernise la Bourse.
Plus aucun pays ne résiste aux charmes
de la mondialisation financière.
Moi, je suis partisan
d'une société d'économie mixte.
Dans laquelle il existe
un secteur public,
où l'État actionnaire doit jouer son rôle,
et un secteur privé,
où les actionnaires privés
doivent jouer leur rôle.
Je ne suis pas partisan
d'une intervention de l'État,
comme c'était autrefois le cas,
dans les sociétés privatisées.
Les sociétés privatisées
sont maîtres de leur destin,
à condition que les actionnaires
aient leur mot à dire.
Mais ce n'est pas à moi d'intervenir.
Aux actionnaires d'user de la liberté
que j'entends leur donner !
La France avait besoin
d'une bourse qui fonctionne.
Les entreprises avaient besoin de capitaux.
On ne doit pas compter sur les contribuables
pour financer les entreprises.
Les contribuables doivent financer
la police, la justice, l'éducation,
un certain nombre de biens publics.
Mais les entreprises, fondamentalement,
sont à financer par des actionnaires.
Or, la France n'avait pas de système
capitaliste qui fonctionne.
Et ce n'était pas d'être socialiste
qui était important,
mais le fait d'être un bon ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances,
de voir ce qu'il se passait
dans le reste du monde,
de le faire et de le mettre en œuvre.
Pierre Bérégovoy décide de favoriser
tout à coup la demande d'actions,
il n'est pas normal que les Français
n'aient pas d'actions,
il faut que les Français aient des actions,
puisque les Américains en ont.
On favorise la demande d'actions mais on
favorise la création de marchés spéculatifs.
on peut spéculer sur la hausse
des valeurs boursières.
Ce qui fait que la place de Paris
commence à concurrencer financièrement
la City de Londres.
Allez, on monte au petit trot !
Bravo Bernard, t'as bien suivi,
viens avec nous.
Allez Bernard, c'est le jogging !
C'est l'époque où l'on voit apparaître
dans les médias les nouveaux apôtres,
de l'économie de marché.
Avec une bonne dose d'entrain, de conviction,
ils nous expliquent la base du monde moderne.
Allez, tout le monde nous suit !
En petite foulée avec Bernard Tapie !
Moi, j'assume.
Je suis un vrai capitaliste.
Qui vit comme un capitaliste.
Moi, j'ai le droit au profit,
je me le donne ce droit !
J'ai le droit d'avoir un jet.
Je l'ai gagné !
C'est redoutable de vivre dans un système
capitaliste avec des gens qui ne le sont pas.
Or, l'unité de mesure d'un système
capitaliste, c'est l'argent.
Il est bien, il est pas bien,
on veut en changer, on n'en change pas.
Mais aujourd'hui, c'est celui-là.
Si vous ne l'acceptez pas, c'est dire
à un sportif "tu oublies le chronomètre",
tu vas courir mais surtout le
chronomètre, ça ne t'intéresse pas.
Ou à un littéraire
"Tu oublies les prix"...
À un moment donné, on est obligé
de s'étalonner sur une unité de mesure.
Pour moi, mon unité de mesure
étant l'argent,
j'entreprends mes affaires et je les fais
entreprendre par tous ceux qui m'entourent,
avec une volonté féroce
de gagner beaucoup d'argent !
Et à mes côtés, pour illustrer l'argent,
j'ai demandé à Paul-Loup Sulitzer,
qui est un homme de la finance,
et qui a écrit notamment 4livres
sur la haute finance,
Money, Cash, Fortune, Le Roi Vert.
Nous en parlerons tout à l'heure.
Je crois que l'argent représente pour vous,
des choses importantes,
vous êtes l'homme, pas le plus riche du monde,
mais avec des propriétés un petit peu partout.
Ce sont mes héros qui sont riches, moi,
je suis d'une fortune bien plus modeste.
L'argent, c'est comme l'air qu'on respire,
c'est important.
D'autant plus que dans le monde actuel,
tout le monde entend parler de l'argent.
L'argent, c'est la grande star,
c'est la vedette.
Même quand elles vivent loin
de Londres ou de New York,
les icônes de la réussite
sociale changent de style.
L'argent devient une divinité adorée.
Désormais, la testostérone
des jeunes gens monte et descend,
au gré des indices boursiers.
Est-ce qu'on prend de la c**** ?
Je ne bois pas, je ne fume pas.
Il faut toujours avoir les idées
claires et lucides.
On commence à 8 h 30 et en général
on termine tard le soir,
car le marché newyorkais en heure
locale ouvre à 3 h 30.
Je crois que ça dépend plus d'une tension
nerveuse, d'un climat de travail.
On n'a pas besoin de se détacher
du métier par des artifices.
Chez les Américains, il y a
une consommation assez sérieuse de tout.
Il y a une tension nerveuse
supérieure à la nôtre.
Les capitaux engagés sont plus importants
donc ils sont bien plus nerveux.
Quand à Paris, on fait 3 milliards,
on est nerveux.
Si on faisait 10 milliards, on aurait
peut-être besoin de palliatifs.
C'est la boisson, les femmes,
il peut y avoir aussi la d****,
je ne sais pas.
Alors que font-ils de tout
l'argent qu'ils gagnent ?
Comme ils se soucient
de leur apparence,
ils dépensent
des fortunes en vêtements.
Jean-philippe se fait
faire du sur mesure.
Et Stéphane Rey, qui a pour 30 millions
d'anciens francs de costumes,
va tous les samedis dans la Porsche
dont il rêvait adolescent,
chez un grand couturier ou une vendeuse,
lui met de côté les dernières créations.
- Bonjour Marie-José.
- Bonjour, j'ai préparé des choses.
Dans les années où la bourse,
prend les commandes de l'économie
mondiale, on fait apparaître,
un gain de productivité artificielle
que le capital récupère.
Ce gain de productivité aurait
dû être traditionnellement,
partagés entre les salariés
et les entrepreneurs,
mais c'est récupéré par les donneurs
d'ordre qui sont les fonds de pension,
les grandes banques, les grandes banques
d'affaires, Lehman Brothers...
Goldman Sachs, c'est toutes
les grandes banques d'affaires,
Wall Street qui a repris la main
sur le fonctionnement du capitalisme.
La première déroute boursière.
Il n'aura pas fallu attendre longtemps
après l'euphorie du Big bang,
pour qu'elle se produise.
Le 19 octobre 1987, Wall Street enregistre
une dégringolade impressionnante.
Pour la première fois depuis 1929,
le spectre du jeudi noir
est sorti de sa tombe,
et recommence à rôder autour de la bourse.
Que s'est-il passé ?
C'est assez simple.
En juin 87, on change de président
de la Réserve fédérale américaine.
Ça paraît anodin,
mais à l'époque, c'est Paul Volcker,
qui est quelqu'un de très crédible,
lui, c'est un bon pilote dans l'avion,
et il est remplacé
par Alan Greenspan, qui depuis,
est devenu quelqu'un de très reconnu.
Quand Alan Greenspan arrive, il veut
se montrer plus royaliste que le roi.
Il dit : "Vous avez vu Paul Volcker ?"
Je suis encore plus dur que lui.
Donc maintenant, ça suffit
cette croissance à outrance.
On va monter les taux d'intérêt,
ça va calmer le jeu.
Évidemment, les marchés n'ont pas du tout aimé
et c'est ce qui a fait ce krach d'octobre 87.
Wall Street est une nouvelle
fois en chute libre.
Certains parlent même de débâcle.
À New York, le commentaire de Paul Nahon.
C'était l'affolement
ce matin à Wall Street,
quelques secondes après l'ouverture
de la Bourse à New York,
le Dow Jones avait perdu 100 points par
rapport à l'indice de vendredi dernier.
Du jamais vu. 77 millions d'actions ont
changé de mains en l'espace d'une heure,
et ce rythme a augmenté jusqu'à 2 millions
d'actions échangées toutes les minutes.
1 h avant la fermeture de Wall Street,
la baisse du Dow Jones était
de 280 points, record absolu.
Le dollar, lui aussi, était en chute.
La Commission américaine des opérations
en Bourse envisage désormais,
d'interrompre le marché pour tenter
d'enrayer la spirale de la baisse.
Les cours baissent de 23-24%
en une journée,
ce qui était à peu près l'ordre
de grandeur qu'on avait connu en 29,
mais sur plusieurs jours.
C'est donc d'une extrême violence.
Partie de New York, l'onde de choc
se propage aussitôt,
à l'ensemble de la planète financière.
Paris n'est pas épargné.
On redécouvre les angoisses
d'un krach boursier.
Cotation en chute libre, traders hystériques, investisseurs effrayés,
épargnants déboussolés
et gouvernement impuissant.
Il faudra bien s'accoutumer
à voir ces scènes d'effervescence,
parce qu'elles ne vont pas cesser
de se reproduire par la suite.
Ce qui était frappant dans la crise de 87,
c'est qu'on est dans un environnement,
où on a une crise
qui est purement boursière.
On est dans une configuration
où l'économie continue à croître.
On est dans une situation
qui est relativement saine.
où il y a simplement un dérapage,
de la spéculation,
une résurgence de l'inflation
et à partir de là,
une explosion de la bulle boursière.
Beaucoup d'économistes en 87
annonçaient la récession pour 88.
Or, on a eu une croissance très forte !
Comme on a réagi, on a baissé
le taux d'intérêt et que finalement,
c'était avant tout une crise boursière.
Ça a ensuite redémarré.
La crise de 87,
elle apparaît comme un chaos,
mais ce que l'on regarde, c'est
le succès du nouveau modèle libéral.
Le succès, c'est quand même
un retour à une croissance forte,
à une baisse du chômage un peu partout,
et au décollage des pays émergents.
Les pays émergents, avant on disait
de façon un peu condescendante,
pays en voie de développement ou pire,
pays sous développés.
La mondialisation de la finance n'est pas
la seule à prospérer dans les années 80.
En parallèle, on assiste
à un autre bouleversement,
la mondialisation
de la production industrielle.
Des pays comme la Chine se lancent tête
baissée dans la compétition internationale.
En effet, nous étions les seuls
dans le monde à maîtriser la technique,
à fabriquer certains objets.
Aujourd'hui, ce n'est plus le cas.
Regardez les objets qu'a acheté madame
Lambert pour son appartement.
Ils ont été fabriqués à des milliers
de kilomètres de chez elle.
Comment cela se fait-il ?
Pourquoi ? Est-ce qu'ils sont
mieux fait, moins cher ?
Plus moderne ?
En réalité, ce qu'ils montrent,
c'est qu'un événement de taille
a frappé l'Europe.
Nous ne sommes plus les seuls
à savoir maîtriser la technique.
Des concurrents sérieux
ont surgi à travers le monde,
et surgissent sans cesse de plus en plus.
Ils font mieux que nous,
plus vite et moins cher.
La croissance des pays développés,
c'est une croissance par l'importation,
ce sont les Chinois qui deviennent
l'atelier du monde.
Tout ce que vous consommez désormais
se fabrique avec du travail,
qui n'est pas payé avec
des conditions sociales normales.
Les Etats-Unis créent
des usines qu'ils implantent,
en Chine ou ailleurs,
rapatrient leur profits,
ont une législation fiscale,
qui font qu'ils ont le droit,
de ne pas déclarer tous ces profits, d'en
placer une partie dans les paradis fiscaux.
C'est absolument légal aux Etats-Unis,
Ce qui fait que du revenu financier
revient aux Etats-Unis.
Mais il faut bien du travail
dans une économie.
Sauf que le travail, ce n'est plus l'ouvrier
de Detroit qui le fournit, ou de moins en moins.
Et c'est vrai qu'on va assister, à partir
des années 80 à une explosion des inégalités,
à une stagnation du salaire moyen.
Et en revanche, les inégalités explosent
et les fortunes se constituent,
grâce à la valeur boursière.
Voici en pleine action,
la classe biberon des Golden boys,
toute la fougue et l'envie
de gagner de leurs aînés et pourtant...
Depuis octobre 87, on ne dit
plus golden boy, on dit plaqué or,
La bourse, c'est comme le fast food,
ça monte, ça descend très vite.
Ce sont de drôles de mecs !
Finalement un plaqué or, c'est un crétin
avec une légère pellicule de billets de banque.
Le crash de 87 ne change pas
véritablement l'état d'esprit,
des milieux d'affaires de Wall Street
et de la figure de tutelle de Wall Street,
Qui est Alan Greenspan, le président
de la Federal Reserve,
parce qu'il connaît la crise de 29
et il sait ce qu'il s'est passé.
Il sait que l'erreur a été de ne pas
mettre de la liquidité au moment de la crise.
À ce moment là, il a cette
phrase extraordinaire, il dit :
"Vous aurez tout le crédit
que vous voulez."
Et on assiste à une explosion
à ce moment là,
de la masse monétaire aux Etats-Unis.
Plus de peur que de mal, se dit on
après la tourmente d'octobre 1987.
De toute façon, avec la toute
puissance des marchés financiers,
nous voilà condamnés à vivre
des krachs à répétition.
Ce sera même un festival,
quasiment une crise tous les deux ans.
Immobilier, devises, obligations,
nouvelles technologies,
aucun marché, aucun pays n'en réchappera.
Tous connaîtront un jour
ou l'autre une débâcle.
Mais qu'on se rassure, maintenant,
on sait manier la baguette magique
de la politique monétaire.
Il suffit de s'arranger avec les taux
d'intérêt et la crise se volatilise,
comme par enchantement.
Parmi la multitude des crises spéculatives,
il y en a eu une,
celle du Japon en décembre 1989,
qui mérite un détour.
Parce que le Japon,
à la différence des autres pays,
a oublié de sortir sa baguette
magique au bon moment.
Depuis une trentaine d'années,
il s'est enfoncé
dans une crise économique.
Jusqu'en 1989, le Japon est pourtant
au summum de sa puissance.
Son dynamisme industriel fascine,
on parle du dragon d'Asie qui est
en train de conquérir le monde.
À l'époque, le Japon avait 6%
de croissance par an.
C'était le modèle absolu,
on ne parlait que du Japon.
On nous dit à l'époque,
la domination américaine c'est terminé,
le pouvoir, ça va être le Japon qui va
devenir la première puissance mondiale.
On cite le prix du mètre carré à Tokyo,
qui vaut 1 million de francs à l'époque.
Les prix de l'immobilier,
les cours de bourse qui avaient flambé,
grâce à un endettement délirant,
s'effondrent brutalement fin 1989,
avec la remontée des taux d'intérêt.
Au cours de la seule année 1990,
l'indice Nikkei dévisse de 40%.
2000 milliards de dollars disparu
de la circulation.
Les Japonais découvrent, effarés, que leurs
banques ont accumulé dans leurs bilans,
des quantités astronomiques
de créances douteuses,
des crédits qu'elles ont distribués
à profusion en contrepartie d'actifs,
qui ne valent plus grand chose.
Le jour où le prix d'un logement
ou d'un bureau,
est disproportionné par rapport au loyer,
ou bien le prix d'une action disproportionné
par rapport aux dividendes qu'on peut en attendre,
Là, la bulle commence à se créer,
parce que les gens n'achètent plus
le logement pour l'occuper ou le louer,
ils n'achètent plus d'action les dividendes,
ils achètent pour revendre.
et ils peuvent le faire à crédit.
Et c'est toujours la même histoire
qui recommence.
Après le krach, la saignée
a été terrible pour le Japon.
Baisse de moitié de la croissance, apparition
du chômage, explosion de la dette publique,
mais surtout la fin d'une longue
période de prospérité économique.
C'était le banquet d'adieu des mineurs.
Fini la tradition de l'emploi à vie,
1791 personnes licenciées,
mais seulement 70 reprisent par Mitsubishi.
Certains des plus grands établissements
financiers du Japon,
sont acculés à la faillite.
Les épargnants, pris de panique
à l'idée de tout perdre se précipitent,
devant les guichets
pour tenter de récupérer leur mise.
Je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer qu'un
des 4 plus gros courtiers japonais,
puisse ainsi s'effondrer.
J'avais confiance dans cette compagnie.
Je suis très déçu !
Mais au moins au Japon,
quand un banquier a commis des fautes,
il est prié de présenter
des excuses publiques.
C'est entièrement de ma faute.
Les employés ne sont pas en cause.
Je me sens responsable de ce qui arrive.
De tous ceux à qui
j'avais promis du travail.
Si quelqu'un pouvait juste trouver
à l'un ou l'autre un nouvel emploi.
Je serai très reconnaissant.
Contrairement aux Américains,
après le krach d'octobre 1987,
la Banque centrale du Japon a longtemps
refusé d'abaisser ses taux d'intérêt
et de secourir un secteur
bancaire à l'agonie.
Une erreur qui coûte cher.
Les autorités nippones ne vont pas
se rendre compte, ils vont être tellement,
sur d'eux qu'ils vont
se dire que tout va bien.
Dans un premier temps, pas de relance,
pas de baisse des taux,
ils vont laisser la crise s'installer
et devenir de la déflation.
Vous ajoutez à cela la baisse
de la population japonaise,
qui est quand même le pire
qui peut arriver pour un pays.
À partir de là, le Japon s'est enfoncé,
dans la déflation.
S'il y a bien une leçon à tirer
de la crise japonaise,
c'est qu'en laissant le système
financier se débrouiller tout seul,
on ne fait que prolonger indéfiniment
les conséquences désastreuses,
de l'éclatement d'une bulle spéculative.
En réalité, sans aide publique, les banques
mettent des années à éponger leurs dettes,
et cessent pendant ce temps là
de financer l'économie réelle.
Tandis que le Japon continue
à s'embourber dans la crise,
l'amérique est frappée de plein fouet
par les attentats du 11 septembre 2001.
Ce jour là, elle a bien cru
que tout pouvait s'écrouler.
Pas seulement les tours du World Trade Center,
mais aussi son modèle économique.
Car le 11 septembre survient
dans un contexte déprimé,
les Etats-Unis, affaiblis par le krach des
nouvelles technologies un an plus tôt,
sont en panne de croissance.
Avec les attentats, ils découvrent de surcroît
la vulnérabilité de leur économie.
Le gouvernement veut laver l'affront
et montrer au monde entier,
que L'oncle Sam relèvera
très vite la tête.
On a tellement peur que du fait des
attentats, l'économie finalement vacille.
Et finalement, les Etats-Unis perdent la
guerre psychologique contre le terrorisme,
il faut relancer la machine
et donc on le fait à tout prix.
Alan Greenspan décide d'inonder
les Etats-Unis d'argent,
il décide de baisser les taux d'intérêt,
et de créer finalement
la bulle du siècle.
2001, c'est une année
charnière aux Etats-Unis,
au cours de laquelle
2 événements majeurs vont se produire.
La première, c'est l'éclatement de la bulle
Internet qui va beaucoup inquiéter,
le président de la banque centrale
américaine de la Fed, Alan Greenspan.
Car Greenspan comprend que la bulle Internet
a été un des arguments majeurs,
de la croissance américaine tout à fait
exceptionnelle des années 90.
Quand cette bulle Internet explose,
Greenspan se dit qu'il a perdu un des
arguments forts de la croissance américaine.
Et puis le deuxième événement,
évidemment d'importance planétaire,
et considérable qui va se produire en 2001,
c'est le 11 septembre
qui est un choc considérable,
sur le moral des Américains,
qui provoquent un effondrement
de la Bourse tout de suite après,
et qui fait penser à Alan Greenspan que,
combinée à l'éclatement quelques mois plus tôt,
de la bulle Internet, l'économie américaine
va durablement souffrir et ralentir.
Pour réagir à ce double choc,
Alan Greenspan va mener à partir de 2001,
une politique monétaire très laxiste.
Ça veut dire qu'il va baisser
plusieurs fois les taux d'intérêt.
Toujours la baguette magique
de la politique monétaire,
quand une crise éclate, on arrose les marchés
financiers de liquidités pour éteindre l'incendie.
Mais en 2001, on passe à la démesure.
C'est un véritable déluge d'argent frais
qui s'abat sur l'Amérique,
l'endettement devient le principal
moteur de l'activité économique.
La seule façon de faire de la croissance,
c'était de mettre du crédit
à la place des salaires.
C'est ce qu'on a fait partout et à nouveau a
vec la complicité des banques centrales,
qui ont maintenu des taux d'intérêt bas.
Parce que si vous voulez mettre du crédit
à la place des revenus massivement,
1 : les banques ne pouvaient pas le faire
puisque le régulateur prudent,
avait dit : si vous faites du crédit,
il faut beaucoup de capital.
Donc les banques ne pouvaient
pas toutes faire crédit.
On a inventé des techniques financières,
la titrisation, pour que les banques,
puissent faire du crédit sans avoir de capital,
en sortant les crédits de leur bilan,
et en mettant ces crédits dans des pseudo
banques qui sont dans les places offshore.
Les banques sont l'instrument
de cette situation,
où on a mis du crédit consciemment
à la place des revenus,
s'il n'y avait eu que les salaires,
il n'y aurait pas eu beaucoup de croissance.
C'est taux d'intérêt très bas, ça va
favoriser une économie d'endettement,
aux Etats-Unis,
d'endettement à tous les niveaux.
Premier niveau, ce sont les ménages,
le taux d'épargne américain qui était
supérieur à 10% au milieu des années 90,
à la veille de cette séquence,
va dégringoler jusqu'à devenir négatif,
ce qui est inouï.
On n'a jamais vu ça !
Les ménages vont dépenser plus
en moyenne qu'ils ne gagnent,
et le crédit va être le moyen presque
social par lequel le ménage américain,
va pouvoir compenser
cette stagnation de revenu.
Scène de la vie ordinaire dans l'Amérique
profonde, le Connecticut chez les Dixon,
tout ou presque se paie à crédit.
Taux d'endettement du ménages,
20 à 25% des revenus annuels.
Marie-Elizabeth et Robert Dixon n'ont
pratiquement jamais de dollars sur eux,
seulement quelques rectangles de plastique,
les indispensables cartes de crédit.
Quand on lui demande combien
de cartes elle possède,
Marie-Elizabeth répond en riant "9",
une pour chaque usage,
car pour elle, ce choix,
cela représente la liberté.
Quant à Robert Dixon, il n'est pas une
semaine où il ne reçoive une sollicitation,
d'un établissement de crédit,
cette fois ci 5 000$ à 18%.
Seule formalité renvoyer
le formulaire signé.
La vie à crédit, les ménages américains seront
les premières victimes de cette fourberie.
Pourtant, à l'origine, il y avait une idée
généreuse de l'administration Clinton.
En 1995, elle avait renforcé
une loi visant à faciliter l'accès,
des plus défavorisés
au crédit et à la propriété.
Mais par la suite,
avec l'énorme afflux de liquidités,
ce système a dangereusement dérapé.
Le départ du subprime,
c'est le Community Reinvestment Act,
c'est l'administration démocrate qui dit,
ce n'est pas normal que 70% des Blancs
soient propriétaires,
et seulement 40% des Noirs.
Donc on va forcer les banques
à prêter aux noirs.
Mais ça procède de la même logique
générale qui est de dire,
finalement, les Etats-Unis
sont une société assez pauvre
quand on regarde les chiffres.
Les salaires réels n'ont pas bougé en 20 ans.
Comment on fait de la croissance
dans une société assez pauvre ?
Il faut prêter aux pauvres !
C'est l'erreur
de la Réserve fédérale,
elle a été trop loin dans
la baisse des taux, ce qui va,
alimenter le crédit
au-delà du raisonnable,
avec notamment la dette subprime.
C'est très simple, on va dire aux ménages
vous allez vous endetter,
non pas sur votre richesse que
vous n'avez pas, ils sont non solvables,
mais sur la valeur du bien que vous allez acheter
mais pas la valeur actuelle, la valeur future.
Avec la plus-value, vous allez
réussir à financer votre dette.
Ça suppose que les prix augmentent,
mais sur 30 ans,
c'est vrai que c'est toujours vrai mais
sur dix ans ça peut ne pas l'être.
On est allé jusqu'à prêter à une femme,
je me souviens, qui avait acheté 17 maisons
alors qu'elle avait aucun salaire.
Donc le système était devenu
complètement fou !
Il y a eu un emballement qui a été rendu
possible justement par le fait,
qu'en même temps la masse d'argent
en circulation a augmenté massivement.
Pour schématiser, les Américains
dépensaient plus qu'ils ne gagnaient.
Les Chinois qui leur vendaient
des biens pour leur consommation,
le finançaient en achetant
des obligations de l'Etat américain,
donc leur prêtaient l'argent.
Les Chinois prêtaient aux Américains
pour vivre au-dessus de leurs moyens.
L'ensemble du monde se trouvait
avec une marge d'argent qui augmentait.
Cette masse d'argent
cherchait à s'investir,
d'où l'expansion excessive du système.
Un chiffre spectaculaire salué
par les marchés,
la plus forte croissance
jamais connue depuis 19 ans.
+ 7,2% au troisième trimestre 2003.
Aux Etats-Unis, tous les indicateurs
économiques laissent croire à une embellie.
La consommation + 6,6%,
les exportations + 9,3%.
ou encore l'investissement + 11,1%.
Dans les salles de marchés des alchimistes
triturent cette énorme masse d'argent,
et prétendent transformer le plomb en or.
Les produits financiers qu'ils inventent,
paraissent tellement miraculeux,
que tout le monde veut en croquer.
La financiarisation de l'économie,
comme on dit, ne connaît plus aucune limite.
On fait n'importe quoi,
on n'y comprend plus rien,
mais il y a tellement de profits à la clé.
Des formules incompréhensibles
pour tout le monde,
des équations ultra-complexes.
Oubliez les golden boys des années 80
et leur formation commerciale,
ce cours de mathématiques ouvre
les portes de la finance mondiale.
Je forme des ingénieurs
quantitatifs pour la banque,
qui sont des scientifiques.
Non, ce ne sont pas des commerciaux.
Ils ont 25 ans, sont ingénieurs
ou polytechniciens,
mais rêvent de travailler dans les banques
à Wall Street ou la City.
Pour travailler dans la finance,
il faut venir là ?
Oui, c'est le meilleur choix.
C'est comme des maths,
sauf qu'à la fin il y a un euro.
Ça rend la chose beaucoup
plus intéressante.
C'est comme des maths, mais ça brille,
ce sont des maths "bling bling".
Diplômés, ils iront dans les plus
grandes banques à Paris ou à Londres,
pour un premier salaire
de 75 000€ par an.
Des carrières très lucratives
mais courte, 10 à 15 ans,
en raison de la pression et du stress.
Dans le trading,
on a le diplômé de grande école,
et tout d'un coup on se met
à embaucher des mathématiciens.
Et là, c'est la grande fracture.
On commence à se dire qu'il y a beaucoup
d'argent à gagner sur les marchés financiers,
et qu'il faut essayer de modéliser
les marchés financiers.
On passe de produits dérivés
à produits structurés.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Comme son nom l'indique, c'est un produit,
une sorte de package marketing,
de plusieurs petits bouts qu'on va mettre,
dans une boite avec un joli nœud et qu'on
va vendre à un prix beaucoup plus élevé.
Celui qui l'achète très rapidement
ne comprend même pas ce qu'il achète,
et celui qui le vend, très rapidement,
comprenant que celui qui l'achète ne sait pas
ce qu'il achète, y met n'importe quoi.
Et on arrive donc à ces fameux produits
toxiques comme les subprimes.
Au début, on fait un beau paquet
et à l'intérieur on met,
que des chocolats de première qualité.
Puis petit à petit, si vous apercevez
que la personne ne fait pas la différence,
entre un chocolat périmé
et un chocolat de première qualité,
vous allez mettre un quart
de chocolat périmé, puis à la fin,
en 2006, on vend des boîtes
de chocolats périmés, voire empoisonnés.
On faisant confiance aux mathématiciens
brillants qui inventait des produits,
avec des équations à n'en plus finir,
personne ne comprenait.
On mettait ça en informatique,
ça tournait dans les programmes.
Le chef de service du jeune homme ne savait pas
comment ça marchait, le produit du jeune homme.
Et évidemment,
encore moins le président de la banque.
Les forts en maths ont pris
le pouvoir dans les banques.
Ils font croire que la finance
est devenue une science exacte,
où l'on gagne à tous les coups.
Notre avenir est entre de bonnes mains.
Réjouissons nous !
Se développe une doctrine du risque zéro
extrêmement dangereuse.
Le risque disparaît parce qu'on titrise
parce qu'on le met sous le tapis.
Ce qui fait que le banquier ne sait plus
ni à qui il prête, ni ce qu'il prête,
ni pourquoi il prête,
donc cette idéologie se développe.
Les banques centrales ont considéré
que la montée du prix de l'immobilier,
ou des actions n'était pas de l'inflation,
parce que simultanément,
les prix dn'augmentaient pas.
Pour la raison très simple :
il y avait la Chine et l'Inde,
qui fournissaient massivement
de la main d'œuvre bon marché,
qui pressaient sur le prix des produits.
Les prix des biens n'augmentant pas,
les banques centrales aussi bien la BCE,
que le Federal Reserve aux Etats-Unis,
toutes les banques centrales,
hésitent à casser une croissance.
Elle dit d'accord, l'immobilier augmente,
mais après tout, il n'y a pas d'inflation.
Or, casser le crédit,
c'est casser la croissance.
On ne sait pas arrêter une bulle
sans arrêter en même temps l'économie.
C'est là qu'est la difficulté.
Un jour, ça leur a pris l'idée
que leur taudis pouvait valoir,
le prix d'un petit paradis.
Et les agences m'ont dit de monter les prix.
Qu'il n'y avait pas que de petits profits.
Puis les chiffres ont gonflé
et les esprits aussi.
Les novices affolées
par la flambée des prix,
se sont tous endettés
en se faisant bercer,
par le discours qui dit
que ça ne baissera jamais.
Quand elle va péter la bulle immobilière,
moi je vous garantis
que les banquiers sont peu fiers.
Quand il va chuter, le pays de la pierre,
je serai content d'être resté locataire.
Plein de gens disent qu'il n'y a
pas une bulle immobilière.
C'est le niveau normal des prix
et pas n'importe qui.
Greenspan soutient qu'il n'y a pas de bulle
immobilière et il continue à le soutenir,
même début 2007,
dans son livre L'âge des turbulences,
d'ailleurs il dit le prix
de l'immobilier ne baissera pas,
il est arrivé à un plateau,
il va rester stable.
On passe d'une phase où les marchés financiers
et la finance est au service de l'économie,
à une phase où la finance
est au service de la finance.
Quand la finance
est au service de la finance,
elle perd le contact avec la réalité.
Mais la réalité finit un jour ou l'autre
par se rappeler à notre souvenir.
Quand en 2006, les taux d'intérêt commencent
à monter et les prix de l'immobilier a baisser,
on comprend que beaucoup d'emprunteurs
ne pourront plus payer leur crédit,
et qu'il faudra les mettre
à la porte de chez eux.
On est encore très loin d'en mesurer toutes
les conséquences sur le système financier.
Jusqu'en juin 2004, les taux d'intérêt
de la Réserve fédérale sont à 1%.
Les ménages s'endettent sur
des taux à 3%. Tout va bien.
Mais deux ans plus tard, les taux de
la Réserve fédérale américaine sont à 5,25%.
Le taux de marché est à 8,5-9%.
Le ménage américain qui payait 3%
maintenant, il va payer 12%,
Il ne peut pas rembourser,
donc il fait faillite.
S'il fait faillite,
le subprime aussi fait faillite.
Le remboursement que je paye aujourd'hui
est très dur à assumer,
et s'il augmente, ce sera encore pire.
Comme elle aux Etats-unis, plus
de 2 millions de propriétaires modestes,
risquent de tout perdre.
En cause, le système
des prêts hypothécaires immobiliers.
Explication : Pour acheter une maison, un
particulier demande un crédit à une banque,
en échange d'une hypothèque sur la maison.
S'il ne peut plus rembourser, la banque
se paye en vendant cette maison.
Mais l'immobilier est en crise,
la valeur des maisons baisse,
pour compenser, les banques
augmentent les remboursements.
Les propriétaires ne peuvent plus suivre,
et les banques perdent des centaines
de millions de dollars.
Certaines font faillite.
Voilà pourquoi la bourse a plongé.
Mais des banques du monde entier
ont spéculé sur ces crédits à haut risque.
Ainsi, la BNP a reconnu avoir
misé sur les crédits américains.
Cela a suffi à faire plonger
les Bourses européennes.
L'histoire retiendra que le début
de la crise, c'est le 9 août 2007,
lorsque BNP Paribas, une banque française,
ferme un de ces fonds,
dont elle n'était plus capable
d'apprécier la liquidité.
C'est ce qui a donné le coup d'envoi.
Si une banque française
n'est pas capable d'assurer,
la liquidité de l'un de ses fonds,
c'est plus grave que prévu.
Les Mccue avaient acheté cette maison
à Las Vegas et brusquement,
les échéances augmentent de 57%.
Vicki perd son travail de secrétaire.
Bill, technicien de maintenance dans
un casino, est licencié, c'est l'engrenage
saisie, expulsion, camping.
On était convaincu
que c'était la bonne solution,
et que nos remboursements mensuels
n'augmenteraient pas de plus de 100$.
On leur faisait confiance, ils nous répétaient
que c'était la meilleure chose à faire.
On ne croit jamais que ça va arriver.
Ça fait mal,
émotionnellement et aussi physiquement.
Je n'ai rien fait pour en arriver là,
ce n'est pas ma faute,
mais personne n'en n'a rien à faire.
Tout le monde vous tourne le dos.
Par un curieux retournement des choses,
ils risquent d'avoir bientôt,
pour compagnons d'infortune ceux là même
qui ont spéculé contre eux,
et qui les ont poussés dehors.
Ces sociétés financières qui tombent comme
des dominos jusqu'au cœur de Wall Street,
entraînant avec elles des dizaines
de milliers d'employés.
Petit à petit,
on commence à se rendre compte que,
tous les établissements ont ces actifs toxiques.
Globalement, il faut imaginer,
une sorte de radiation nucléaire.
et on pense que finalement
le champ est restreint
et petit à petit, on se promène
avec un appareil et on s'aperçoit,
qu'il y a des radiations partout.
Tout le monde est contaminé.
Au début de l'année 2008, la contamination
atteint l'ensemble des banques.
Leurs protestations de vertu
ne trompent plus personne.
C'est bien le système tout entier
qui est gangréné par les subprimes.
Comme d'habitude, les banques centrales
interviennent et abaissent les taux d'intérêt.
Mais cette fois, l'ardoise est tellement
élevée que la baguette magique n'opère plus.
Le mirage de la finance
tourne au cauchemar,
les États eux mêmes
sont appelés à la rescousse.
Nous traversons un passage difficile,
mais une chose est certaine,
nous avons pris des mesures décisives.
La Fed a agi rapidement
pour ramener de l'ordre
sur les marchés financiers.
Le Premier ministre britannique
a le visage des mauvais jours.
Flanqué de son ministre des Finances,
Gordon Brown doit défendre devant la presse
une décision qui ne lui ressemble pas.
Nationalisé, presqu'un gros mot
aux yeux de ses deux hommes.
C'est pourtant bien ce qu'ils vont faire
avec la banque Northern Rock.
Nous aurions pu vendre
Norther Rock à un privé.
Nous aurions pu accepter l'offre
de Richard Branson,
mais nous avons pensé, et ce ne fut
pas une décision facile à prendre,
que ceux que nous devions privilégier
à long terme étaient les contribuables.
Qui a dit que l'Amérique était libérale ?
L'État va procéder
à une nationalisation géante,
celle de deux agences de crédit
ruinées par la crise de l'immobilier,
montant de l'opération
200 milliardsde dollars.
L'objectif est d'éviter
un krach et de rassurer les marchés.
Fannie Mae et Freddie Mac sont si gros
et tellement impliqué
dans notre système financier,
que la faillite,
ne serait-ce que d'une d'entre elles,
aurait des conséquences incalculables
sur les marchés financiers.
Effectivement, à gros problèmes,
grosses solutions.
Freddie Mac et Fannie Mae
sont des mastodontes.
Ces deux sociétés sont au bout de la chaîne
du crédit immobilier aux États-Unis.
Lorsqu'une banque a besoin de liquidités,
elle peut revendre ses créances,
à l'une de ses institutions
qui en devient alors propriétaire.
Elles possèdent ainsi près
de 50% des crédits aux États-Unis.
Leur encours s'élève à 5200 milliards
de dollars, le tiers du PNB américain.
Lorsque le marché est bon,
que les emprunteurs remboursent,
généralement leur crédit,
Freddie et Fannie sont de formidables
machines à sous.
Mais lorsque le marché s'inverse...
Leurs pertes sont aussi abyssales
que leurs profits jadis.
Quand il y a des profits, ça va au privé.
Quand il y a des problèmes,
c'est pour le contribuable.
C'est exactement cela. Le secrétaire au Trésor
a annoncé mettre 200 milliards sur la table,
et procédait à une nationalisation de fait
des deux sociétés.
Si rien n'était fait, c'était l'effondrement
des marchés, cela aurait été 1929,
on serait passé de la récession
à la dépression.
200 milliardsde dollars qui s'ajoutent
aux 9600 milliards de la dette américaine.
Et à partir de là,
c'est le château de cartes.
Là, on intervient à toute vitesse
pour nationaliser.
On met de l'argent.
c'est de l'argent dans le sable
car on ne sait pas encore,
où sont les crédits pourris,
On sait que tout va se propager
de place financière en place financière.
Sans être spécialiste de la
finance, il y a des noms prestigieux,
que chacun connaît Rothschild,
Morgan ou Lehman Brothers.
C'est cette dernière banque d'affaire
qui est ruinée aujourd'hui.
Elle annonce sa mise en faillite,
c'est un coup de tonnerre,
et aussi le signe que la fameuse crise
des subprimes n'est pas du tout terminée.
Nous voilà revenu au point de départ
le 15 septembre 2008.
L'administration Bush, horrifiée d'avoir
dû nationaliser plusieurs banques,
décide de faire un exemple en laissant
Lehman Brothers sombrer. Erreur fatale.
La bourse n'a pas du tout apprécié
et les gros ennuis ont commencé.
On passe sans transition,
d'un mouvement d'euphorie à la panique,
à un moment donné où la peur fait
que tous les acteurs, progressivement,
vont s'arrêter d'investir ou de consommer.
C'est là où l'économie réelle s'enroule
autour de l'économie financière.
Les deux jouent l'une et l'autre
vers une spirale négative terrible.
La récession fait qu'il y a
de plus en plus de mauvais crédits,
et comme il y a plus de mauvais crédits,
les banques perdent de plus en plus
d'argent, elles prêtent moins,
elles sont plus réticentes
et l'économie réelle tombe.
La panique a gagné toutes les bourses le jour
le plus bas. Titre demain Libération.
Que les indicateurs passent
1 à 1 au rouge.
L'industrie automobile accuse le coup.
Le géant de l'acier, Arcelormittal va mettre
à l'arrêt 3 hauts fourneaux.
Le gouvernement islandais n'hésite pas à
évoquer le risque de faillites d'État.
Il n'y a pas qu'aux Etats-Unis, en Asie et en
Europe que les marchés financiers s'effondrent,
ceux du Golfe doivent faire face, en plus,
à l'effondrement des cours du pétrole.
Pour la Grande-Bretagne, là-bas aussi,
c'est du jamais vu au pays du libéralisme,
le gouvernement a donc annoncé
la nationalisation partielle,
des principales banques du pays. Des banques
qui avaient lancé un appel au secours.
Rien ne semble pouvoir enrayer la crise qui
s'aggrave à chaque nouvelle annonce négative.
Le krach d'octobre 2008 n'est-il
qu'un accès de faiblesse,
comme la Bourse en a souvent
connu depuis 30 ans ?
La situation économique peut-elle
s'améliorer rapidement ?
Vu l'ampleur de la crise actuelle,
c'est malheureusement peu probable.
C'est la 1ere fois dans l'histoire qu'on a
5 continents qui sont frappés en même temps.
C'est à la fois une crise immobilière,
une crise des marchés financiers,
une crise du crédit,
une crise du système bancaire
et puis une crise de l'économie réelle.
Je pense qu'il va y avoir une période de
calme où on va croire que tout est fini,
puisque le Fonds monétaire
international annonce,
une reprise de l'économie américaine
pour 2010-2011.
Mais je pense qu'ensuite la stagnation
va recommencer, peut-être même,
avec une légère dépression,
et qu'à ce moment là, il faudra sortir,
et revenir à une redéfinition du partage.
Parce que derrière l'économie,
il y a la question du partage.
Peut-être que ce sera un nouveau
compromis social qui va succéder,
à ce compromis tout libéral des années 80.
Le retour rapide à la situation d'avant,
à mon avis, il n'existe pas.
On aura une reprise extrêmement progressive,
chaotique et avec des retours en arrière.
Si c'est le retour à une croissance
positive, je pense que, aux Etats-Unis,
c'est possible pour 2010 à cause
de l'ampleur de la mobilisation,
des moyens de la politique économique.
En Europe, je pense que
ça ne s'améliorera pas avant 2011-2012,
à cause de l'insuffisance des moyens de
la politique économique qui ont été mobilisés.
La meilleure politique de relance possible,
c'est celle qui soutient
l'activité d'aujourd'hui
et qui prépare la compétitivité de demain.
Montant du plan au total 26 milliardsd'euros
selon l'Elysée, l'équivalent de 1,3% du PIB.
De quoi creuser le déficit.
À ceux qui me disent ça coûte cher
d'investir, très bien.
Et ça coûte encore plus cher
que de payer l'indemnisation du chômage
et les allocations sociales
parce qu'on a détruit de l'emploi.
À quelques jours de son investiture,
le futur président
veut frapper fort et vite,
car il y a urgence à sortir
le pays de la récession.
Le chômage est à 7% mais pourrait atteindre
10% en 2009 si rien n'est fait, dit-il.
Son arme ? Un plan de relance qui pourrait
atteindre 775 milliardsde dollars,
sur deux ans, soit deux fois
le budget de la France.
Un plan sous forme de baisses d'impôts
et de dépenses publiques.
Il n'y a aucun doute, le coût de ce plan
sera considérable.
À court terme, cela va s'ajouter
aux déficits actuels.
Mais il est certain aussi que
ne rien faire ou faire juste un peu,
amènerait encore plus
de pertes d'emplois, de revenus
et de confiance en notre économie.
Pour le moment, on s'est contenté de colmater
les brèches car tous les gouvernements,
ont eu la même obsession quand le krach
boursier s'est produit, ne pas laisser faire,
comme aux États-Unis en 1929, ne pas perdre
de temps, comme au Japon dans les années 90.
Ils ont agi vite et fort, sans prendre de
gants avec les dogmes du libéralisme.
Entre les plans de relance budgétaire
et les plans de sauvetage des banques,
les États ont injecté au total 5000 milliards
de dollars dans l'économie mondiale.
Mais avec quelles conséquences ?
Et qui va payer ?
Il faut d'urgence relancer la machine.
On regardera plus tard qui paie
et comment on paye l'addition. Allez-y !
C'est un peu une économie d'urgence.
Le malade est sur la table d'opération.
On le ranime d'abord
avant de lui demander des comptes.
Mais le risque énorme qui se profile
à l'horizon, c'est de voir,
par l'accumulation des dettes publiques,
tout à coup, une économie s'effondrer.
C'est bien pour cette raison qu'on a donné
au Fonds monétaire international,
1000 milliards de dollars pour
qu'il puisse intervenir en urgence,
si la Hongrie s'effondre,
si le Mexique s'effondre,
si l'Islande s'effondre.
Il arrivera en disant :
"Attention, je suis là."
Et les États vont être confrontés
à des dettes gigantesques.
Comment fait-on avec la dette ? Il y a 3 moyens.
Les augmentations d'impôts,
l'inflation qui est le deuxième moyen.
et il y a surtout la croissance
qui est le seul vrai moyen,
de rembourser les dettes
et de désendetter les États.
L'objectif numéro 1 de la politique économique,
c'est de faire repartir le crédit
et que si on critique les banques,
ce n'est pas parce qu'elles ont trop prêté,
c'est parce qu'elles ne prêtent pas
assez aujourd'hui. Ce qui est étonnant.
Ce qui crée un truc totalement
schizophrène et bizarre,
où les mêmes gouvernants vous expliquent
que les banquiers sont responsables,
parce qu'ils ont prêté à n'importe qui
et ont déguisé le risque...
Et que, en même temps, les banquiers
compromettent l'économie,
parce qu'ils ne prêtent pas
assez maintenant.
Les gouvernements n'ont pas d'autres idées
aujourd'hui pour faire repartir les économies,
que de remettre du crédit.
On fait ça depuis 1987,
première crise de ce type,
et on a usé le modèle.
Je suis un trader dépendant,
je fais d'hasardeux placements.
À ma banque et à mes clients,
je fais perdre beaucoup d'argent.
Avec vous, je fais le serment
d'essayer chaque jour humblement,
de modérer les investissements.
Et pour tous ces milliards manquants,
je demande pardon aux gens.
Pardon !
Il y a 30 ans, on a voulu
se débarrasser du monstre étatique,
en pensant que tout irait pour le mieux.
On s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
qu'on a enfanté un autre monstre,
celui de la finance, et que la situation
est encore pire.
Même Alan Greenspan, ex-patron vénéré
de la banque centrale américaine
et magicien de la politique monétaire pendant
2 décennies, doit admettre son erreur.
Une confession stupéfiante.
Du coup, nous sommes perdus,
car trop d'incertitudes
subsistent aujourd'hui.
Comment contrôler
les excès du système bancaire ?
Comment débarrasser l'économie
de son accoutumance à l'endettement ?
Comment empêcher que les instincts
animaux se déchaînent à nouveau,
sur les marchés financiers ?
Le monde de la finance n'est pas
soumis à la rationalité.
Le monde des marchés financiers,
c'est le monde,
où on essaie de croire qu'on peut gagner
plus d'argent en prenant moins de risques.
Déjà là, on est dans l'irrationalité
la plus totale.
La sophistication de la finance,
c'est curieusement,
une des inventions perpétuelles
pour amoindrir les risques.
Et finalement, à la fin,
ça les a multiplié à l'infini.
Cette mathématisation
à outrance de la finance.
On ne nous l'a pas imposé,
c'est nous-mêmes qui l'avons fait.
On est tous responsables.
Ce n'est pas un crime organisé
comme certains veulent le faire croire.
Ça, c'est faux !
Ça fait plaisir, ça flatte nos instincts
vengeurs, mais c'est faux !
Adieu les traders, adieu joggings,
les briefings à l'heure Breitling.
Ouvriers, riez.
Adieu les blouses grises.
En Chine, l'usine, on délocalise.
Les cours,
ont dégringolé,
Les banques ont pu rigoler.
La boîte a coulé, mais pouce !
On va se la couler douce.
La pilule, on va, se la dorer
J'ai le parachute doré !
On ne pourra jamais supprimer
la spéculation des marchés financiers,
sinon il faut fermer les marchés,
tout simplement.
La spéculation fait partie
de la vie des marchés.
Un rôle salutaire, c'est ce qui permet
de financer l'investissement innovant,
de couvrir les risques que certains
ne prennent pas.
La spéculation doit rester
la partie émergée de l'iceberg.
Quand elle devient l'iceberg complet,
c'est très dangereux.
Vous avez une addiction
aux investissements à risques.
Vous êtes, je suis, nous sommes
des traders compulsifs.
Bonne nouvelle, il existe un moyen
de s'en sortir, la méthode Yes !
"You can stop".
Oui, vous pouvez arrêter !
C'est un c ou un e au milieu ?
Excusez-moi, vous avez perdu
30 ou 50 millions la semaine passée ?
Vous voulez vous en sortir oui ou non ?
Oui...
D'autres questions ?
Après sa crise, on sait très bien
comment éviter qu'elle ne recommence.
En général la crise suivante est différente.
On peut dire une chose à l'avance,
c'est qu'il y aura encore
des crises financières,
à l'avenir, j'espère qu'elles seront moins
graves que celles que nous traversons.
Mais je peux d'ores et déjà dire
qu'elles seront dues à d'autres causes.
Parce que toutes les causes
de la dernière crise seront corrigées.
Les marchés, personne n'en conteste
la bonne utilité,
dès lors qu'ils sont encadrés, dès lors
que leurs excès sont limités ou interdits,
dès lors qu'on les régule bien.
Je ne crois pas du tout qu'on va même limiter l'innovation d'une façon générale,
et dans les banques en particulier.
Ce qu'il faudrait, c'est que l'innovation
au lieu d'être mise,
au service de la spéculation,
elle soit mise au service,
du financement de l'économie réelle
et du financement de l'économie,
des gens qui en ont besoin
et qui ont des projets.
Mieux encadrer le système financier,
d'accord. Mais après ?
S'il n'y a plus la pompe à crédit
pour gonfler la croissance
et les créations d'emplois,
il faudra bien inventer autre chose.
Je pense que les financiers sont
dans leur bulle financière justement,
dans leur idéologie du tout marché,
dans leur idéologie de la dérégulation
et qu'ils ne voient pas les problèmes réels,
je pense qu'il faut compter sur les politiques
et l'opinion et l'exemplarité de certains.
De ce côté là, quand vous voyez quelqu'un
qui est amateur de voitures de sport,
comme Schwarzenegger, qui considère
que c'est la voiture électrique,
qui doit prendre le pas
sur les autres,
ça veut dire qu'une partie de l'élite
commence à comprendre.
Et si l'élite comprend,
le reste de la population suivra.
La seule solution, c'est de trouver
des industries, des secteurs,
qui créent des emplois
raisonnablement bien qualifiés,
avec des salaires raisonnablement élevés.
Évidemment,
vient à l'esprit le green business,
tout ce qui tourne autour des énergies
renouvelables, de l'environnement,
de l'isolation...
La seule bonne piste, c'est d'être
capable de créer des emplois,
pour lesquels on a une avance
sur les pays émergents.
Il ne faudrait pas se faire piquer
le green business par les Chinois.
C'est dans les dix prochaines
années qu'on sera si,
au-delà de la seule réglementation
du capitalisme financier, on arrivera.
à réfléchir à un modèle social, nouveau.
qui soit capable d'accorder plus
de sécurité aux gens qu'ils n'en ont eu,
au cours des 20-30 dernières années.
Comment assurer une prospérité
durable pour le plus grand nombre ?
Quel rôle l'Etat doit-il se réserver
dans le fonctionnement de l'économie ?
Quelle liberté peut-on raisonnablement
accorder aux marchés ?
C'est beaucoup de question à résoudre
et personne, pas même les experts,
n'y ont encore apporté
de réponses définitives.
On avance toujours en plein brouillard.
Pourtant, il faudra bien
que nous retrouvions une boussole,
car c'est le sort du capitalisme
lui-même qui se joue en ce moment.